or ask which of the following
expressions are equivalent to 2 minus
9.4 plus 0 plus 3.71 and we need to pick
two answers so pause this video and see
if you can have a go at it before we do
this together
all right now let's look through the
choices so this first choice we have
9.4 here we subtracted 9.4 now when you
subtract a number you can also view it
as adding its opposite so we could
rewrite this top thing as 2 plus
negative 9.4 notice when we subtract 9.4
that's the same thing as adding negative
9.4 so we could write it this way
and when you are adding numbers and
that's actually this property or this
principle that we just use is really
useful because when you're adding
numbers like this it doesn't matter what
order you add them in when you when you
have some subtraction involved now all
of a sudden the order does matter but
when you're adding like this it doesn't
matter the order that you are doing it
with so we can swap these numbers any
way we want we could write this for
example as negative 9.4 plus 2 plus 3.71
we could ignore the zero or put that
anywhere obviously plus zero something
like that but what we see over here they
don't have a negative 9.4 they have a
positive 9.4 so I really don't know how
I can reconcile this first thing and
this right over here so I'm going to
rule that one out now this one over here
you have a two
we have a two there
we have a 3.71 we have a 3.71 there and
both of those things are just being
added and now we have a and now from
that we are subtracting 9.4
and so here they're subtracting 9.4
and it is indeed the case here you have
to be very careful with subtraction if
if you know we wouldn't want to make it
9.4 minus something else but as long as
we are only subtracting the 9.4 then the
swapping of this order does work and you
can even verify that with the numbers
over here you could do 2 minus 9.4 Plus
3.71 or you can do 2 plus 3.71 minus 9.4
so I like this choice
now let's look at this one this has 3.71
3.71 it has the two it has the two
and now it's adding 9.4 now we already
said we could rewrite subtracting 9.4 as
adding negative 9.4 but we can't rewrite
that as just adding 9.4 if this had a if
this was like this if it had a negative
there then this would work but it's not
that and so I'm going to I'm going to
rule that one out and I'm guessing this
one's going to work but let's see so
this one put parentheses around it so
it's really just telling us what we want
to do first so it says first do the 2
minus 9.4 which if you just went left to
right you would have done anyway and
then plus 0 plus 3.71 and 0 plus 3.71
obviously that's just going to be 3.71
so of course this does seem very
reasonable to do then you could go 2
minus 9.4
plus 3.71 2 minus 9.4 the 0 doesn't
matter here and then plus 3.71 so I like
that choice let's do another example
so once again we want to come up with an
equivalent with equivalent expressions
so let's look at this one actually
before I even look at the choices let's
just recognize that if you subtract a
number it's the same thing as adding its
opposite so for example this could be
Rewritten as negative six-fifths plus
one half
plus the opposite of negative eight
fifths which is positive eight-fifths
that's another way we could rewrite it
that might be helpful let's see over
here
we have one half which we see right over
there we have plus eight fifths and
interestingly that looks like the one
that we did in the second version right
over here and then we have minus six
fifths so is minus six-fifths the same
thing as this over here well think about
it what we're really doing when we write
this negative six fifths out front
that's the same thing as we could do
that as plus negative six fifths and
that's going to be the same thing as
subtracting the opposite of it or
another way of thinking about it as
subtracting
subtracting positive six fix let me
write it this way subtracting
subtracting positive six fifths it's
actually hard to tell because I put that
I have actually let me write it this way
if we just took it if we just took this
version and we were to if we were to use
a commutative property to swap the
orders we could write this as one-half
plus eight-fifths and then plus negative
six-fifths all I did is swap the order
and now we know that this last part
could be Rewritten so it's one half plus
eight-fifths instead of plus negative
six fifths that can be Rewritten as
negative or minus I should say minus
positive six fifths why can I do that
because subtracting a number is the same
thing as adding its opposite and so all
of these are equivalent and this is
exactly what they have written here this
last scenario so I like that one now
let's see this one has a negative
six-fifths
and it has a plus eight fifths and a
plus one-half so all they did is they
took this version which mean U is
equivalent and they swapped the order
that we are doing they actually swapped
the order of the one half and the eight
fifths and when you're dealing with
addition like this you can move things
around the commutative property you can
you can do your addition in different
orders and that's all they're doing
actually this is not just commutative
this is also associative they're
literally putting that parentheses there
and say hey let's just do and let's just
do the those first two first let's swap
these two and then of course even if
you're going left to right you would do
these first two even if the parentheses
weren't there so you can definitely all
of this is definitely equivalent to
negative six-fifths swapping the
one-half and the eight-fifths so eight
fifths plus one-half so I like that
choice too and so we had two choices so
these are probably not going to work and
let's see why they don't real fast they
both have the negative six fifths this
has the plus one half
but it has minus eight fifths instead of
minus negative eight fifths it it could
have plus eight fifths here but not
minus eight fifths so we roll that one
out negative six-fifths and let's see
then it has
it's adding negative eight-fifths
instead of subtracting negative eight
fifths so I don't like that and then it
subtracts one half instead of adding
one-half so it's no good on multiple
Dimensions let's do one last example
which of the expressions are equivalent
as always pause and see if you can
figure that out
so let's see so actually before I look
at the choices I'm gonna I'm gonna see
if there's different ways to rewrite
this we could rewrite this as 1.7
minus 8.33 why can I do that again
because subtracting a number is the same
thing as adding its opposite and then I
could say plus I could write this as
8.33 and if I wanted to I could even
write this instead of minus 1.95 I could
even write that as plus negative
1.95 if I choose because once again
subtracting a number is the same thing
as adding its opposite now I'm tempted
to try to compute this because we could
just we could just when we're doing
addition like this and I could write it
like this if I want everything to be
addition 1.7 plus negative
8.33 plus 8.33 plus negative 1.95 when
everything is expressed in addition we
know that the order doesn't matter the
commutative property tells us that and
even the associate the associative
property tells the the how we put the
parentheses doesn't matter and so we
could actually do that first and then
these two would cancel out actually
maybe we will have to do that that
choice looks like that but let's just go
step by step so this has 1.7 1.7 let me
do this in a different color one point
that's not a different color
1.7 1.7 they're subtracting 8.33
that's subtracting 8.33 here so that's
equivalent to this version right here
then they're subtracting it again
no this does not look good because even
when we try to compute it we know that
this and these two terms will cancel out
each other so I'm I don't like that one
let's see this one
if we take if we take this one here and
we were to reorder it because this is
all addition of different integers here
but if we were to reorder it we could
reorder it as negative 8.33 negative
8.33
plus 8.33 plus 8.33
plus 1.7 plus 1.7 and then we have plus
negative 1.95 which we know we can write
as minus 1.95 minus 1.95 because
subtracting a number is the same thing
as adding its opposite and that's what
they have here they put these
parentheses but if even if you just went
right if you just went left to right I
should say with this one you're going to
get the same thing so I like that choice
there
now this choice if you just cancel these
two terms out you're left with a 1.7
plus negative 1.95 which we already know
is the same thing as minus 1.95 so I
like this Choice as well now why won't
this one work let's see 1.95
they're trying to change the order but
you can add a negative 1.95 and then put
it out front but this is a positive 1.95
so I'm already not liking this and then
they're subtracting 1.7 there's no
reason why you should subtract 1.7 so
this is definitely not looking good